I'm Angela Lee-Smith.
I teach Korean and English
at the East Asian Languages
and Literatures department.
Today, the summary of
my presentation is--
oops.
I try go to the next slide.
Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
You should be able to.
Oh.
[INAUDIBLE] OK.
So I implemented audio
portfolios my students.
And these portfolios are
perfect examples of progress
in evidenced-based approach.
And I use Canvas tool
audio-video submission.
And it is totally
free, just for you.
[LAUGHTER]
So why portfolios?
Because we oftentimes
face great challenges
to ensure every students
progress and achieve something
after the semester.
So we need some kind
of instructional tools
to identify how to adjust
[INAUDIBLE] strategies.
And as you all know,
we have a slogan
that, No Child Left Behind.
And that applies even in this
higher education environment.
So as I said, portfolios
allows me to practice progress
in evidence-based
teaching practice
and makes learning as a
continued and ongoing process.
So as you see here,
this is the example
of elementary
Korean course site.
And I assigned four
portfolio assignment.
So every two weeks, students
record their speaking
on the given topics in
a day, just to submit.
And this is the
instructor's site.
And you see students
have two choices.
They can either submit
audio files, or video files.
Some students
prefer video files,
so they get to see their
messy dorm room background.
[LAUGHTER]
And then, once they submit
their speaking file,
I get to listen to their
file and analyze and then
immediately provide my feedback.
And so this one,
I can either type,
or I can even
upload my speaking.
So especially, for an
elementary language course,
the pronunciation
is very critical.
So that really helps.
So Canvas built-in
audio-video submission tool
really allows me to use
my students' performance
data to check their progress.
And then, help me
make more informed
instructional decisions.
And I can monitor my
students very closely
and provide them with
frequent feedback.
So is this totally
stress-free and worth it.
And let's utilize it more.
That's it.
Any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
So like sales piece for Canvas.
[LAUGHTER]
And then you get 24-7,
non-stop support.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
Yes?
Did you have students
[INAUDIBLE] about the interface
at all?
Or did you have to
help students with it?
Not ever.
This is very easy.
They get to see the button,
either audio recording,
or video clip recorded,
and then Submit button.
That's it.
Yeah.
Yes?
And you mentioned
that it's stress-free?
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
I don't know how many students
you have in your class, but--
30.
There are three sections.
So it must be a stress for you
to give each one a feedback?
Do you record audio
files to feed back?
Only for the necessary cases.
Oh.
Yes.
But I listen every single one.
Right.
Every two weeks.
And it's not stress at all.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes?
So you give feedback
to everybody?
Yes.
You do give feedback?
I give every single
one feedback, yes.
Even though it's not
good, I say, good, but--
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
So it's a very rewarding
experience, both for me
and students.
So at the end of
semester, students
get to listen to
their from day one
file to the end of the file.
And then, they can
clearly listen and see
how they improved.
So it's a really
rewarding experience.
Yes?
Actually, [INAUDIBLE]
answer that.
So you said these are
restricted to you?
Is there a way to have
them so the students could
see each other, to do some
sort of peer evaluations?
That's only for the 101
tutorial session with the TAs.
So the TA get to
listen to each file.
And then, they share.
And then, only
every two weeks, we
get to have the session
[INAUDIBLE] time.
So we get to pick some
files I would really like
to get students' attention.
And then, we practice together.
OK.
So you have to pick which ones
the other students can see.
Yes.
OK.
Yeah.
Yes?
I think it is possible in
Canvas to have a peer evaluation
type of design there,
but you might not
want to do that at the 101.
Yeah, I do use the function,
because the students usually--
even very hard to listen to
their own voice, so they say,
no.
So we just get together, and
then go through it together.
Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
Some of my students had
a technical problem when
they are recording themselves.
And I asked them to
ask [INAUDIBLE] people.
And then, I don't know if you
have any problem like that.
Before using Canvas, I
had the same problem,
because the students
used their phone
and tried to upload their file.
But they used laptop, and
they use the Canvas tool.
Yeah, but [INAUDIBLE]
And they don't have to upload--
Right.
They couldn't record
on the screen.
I don't know what's the problem.
And the Canvas people
said they're trying
to figure out the problem.
I'm wondering if
that's been fixed.
As far as I know,
we did testing,
and we couldn't find
any issues ourselves.
So it might be configurations
on their own laptops or machines
that they're using.
But we'd be happy to have
them bring in their laptops
and have us look at it.
But the system seems to be
working for other students,
so it must be specific to
whatever configuration's
on their machines.
So if they have a problem,
just go to Kimberly.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
Jen.
Where is Jen?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]